[Music]
welcome to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have a great show for you today uh this
is our first episode of the new season
and also our first real like
non-fireside chat episode of the new
podcast lineup with uh with me and lens
on the mics and uh yeah Seasons back
baby we're we're excited for the return
of the Pod
um from now until yeah I don't want to
say exactly when but at least at least a
few months from now uh expect new
episodes in your feeds every two weeks
uh it will be alternating with the
newsletter we also send out every two
weeks so it'll be podcast week
newsletter week podcast week newsletter
week you you get the point
um Linds do you wanna do you want to
talk about the newsletter real quick
yeah yeah I'll just talk about it real
quick just so people know what it is
um I think it's a good compliment to the
show
it's something that Greg and I
collaborate on where he writes a review
of a recent paper and we publish that as
an article on the website and then I
kind of edit that down into a really
digestible version for Instagram and for
the newsletter and so if you want to get
just really concise reviews of recent
research we send those out every other
Wednesday along with other articles and
things like that that we publish on the
website so we really try to keep the
quality of the things that we're sending
you in your inbox hi because we know
that a lot of people will just Spam you
but I think it's worth signing up for
and you can do that at Stronger by
science.com newsletter or there's a form
right at the top of the home page so
just stormy science.com absolutely so
just to get this out of the way early uh
for long time fans of the podcast uh you
might notice that uh previously it was
Eric and I on the podcast now it is me
and Lindsay uh so there's a bit of a
change there uh Eric has has moved on uh
so happy trails to him he is he is no
longer working with Stronger by science
he's taken a job uh he's taken a
research position working at Duke in
Hermann ponce's lab
um so you know gonna gonna be doing a
lot more primary research on things like
the constrained energy model energy
expenditure variability a lot of
exciting stuff a lot of lines of
research that that have interested him
for years so uh we're we're very excited
for him and we we wish him nothing but
the best in his future endeavors But
Here and Now at Stronger by science the
The Show Must Go On the podcast must
continue uh people people demand their
audio content so we are carrying on Linz
and I and uh I'm excited I I think this
is going to be a lot of fun
um but
you know this is a new podcast lineup
obviously so
uh the the Dynamics are probably going
to be a little bit different the banter
is probably going to be a little bit
different the uh exact kind of like
segments and formula of the podcast uh
will will probably change and be
somewhat up in the air for a while while
we settle in on a format and dynamic
that feels good to record and that the
audience enjoys as well so uh yeah there
there's probably going to be a bit of
experimentation over the next couple of
months and so uh if if you could we
would very much appreciate it if you
could just give us a little bit of Grace
while we settle into a new podcast
format uh but we we're we're very
excited and and optimistic about where
this thing is going to go
um one more thing to note is a popular
segment of the old podcast was a just
kind of like rapid fire q a segment
where we tried to get through as many
questions as we could relatively quickly
uh one of the things we want to try with
with this new season coming back is a
slightly different approach to q and A's
um
so one one of the things that always
felt a little bit weird about the Q a
segments before was uh just us picking a
question and reading it and then
immediately launching into answering it
in our own voice like uh sometimes no I
I should I shouldn't admit this but
sometimes it's hard to read on Mike and
then people are like
does this guy not know how to read is he
illiterate and like honestly maybe a
little bit but uh you know it's it's a
lot of pressure and people might like
phrase things weird or like use weird
punctuation whatever like it's it I I
didn't feel like that flowed as well as
it possibly could have it's also best
for people to pronounce their own names
that seems like a difficult thing as
well yes yes that is also true uh and
and as someone who has a name that that
is frequently mispronounced or or
misspelled that's something I'm
sensitive to
um so yeah we're going to try something
new with the Q and A's we've set up a
new email inbox that is podcast at
strongerbyscience.com and if you have a
question that you'd like to have
answered on the show uh record a voice
message and send it to that email
address that is again podcast
strongerbyscience.com try to keep it
under 30 seconds but just just being
straight up with you you if it's over 60
seconds we're not going to listen to it
um we we just don't have time to do that
and just for for the benefit of the show
that would just kind of kind of drag I
guess yeah it's like a third host almost
right somebody just writes in 10 minute
voice memo yes so if you if you have a
question we would love to answer it on
the show send us a voice message to just
record a voice memo on your phone send
it to that address uh that is how we are
going to do q and A's but again keep it
snappy try to keep it under 30 seconds
definitely keep it under 60. uh beyond
that you know standard uh standard
things to get through at the top of each
episode if you're looking for an
excellent nutrition app that will Coach
you along as you try to gain weight lose
weight maintain weight uh take a lot of
the cost of decision making uh off of
your plate you should check out our new
nutrition app macro Factor if you're
looking for a excellent coach to help
you pursue any Fitness or body comp
related goals you you could possibly
have check out Stronger by science
coaching we have a team of excellent
coaches there who who would love to help
you out
um if you're looking for a research
review to keep up to date with with all
of the cool research coming out related
to strength strength Sports physique
Sports getting jacked getting ripped Etc
check out Mass monthly applications and
strength sport
I guess it doesn't have a formal link to
this podcast anymore I I left it a
couple months back Erica's no longer
here but guess what it's still [__]
rocks it's a great it's a great product
you should check it out
um it's still just absolutely cooking
and the the person who replaced me at
Mass Lauren Colin so simple uh her her
contributions to her first few episodes
have been very strong uh replacing me
with Lauren I think has been a clear
upgrade for Mass so if if you haven't
checked it out or if you subscribe
before uh and and you're you're curious
about what's what's going on there these
days check it out again it's awesome uh
and finally if you'd like uh good
supplements on the cheap check out
bulksupplements.com use code SBS POD at
checkout and that will that will get you
a discount on your order and finally if
you'd like to keep up to date with what
we're doing uh and and in particular if
you'd like to connect with like-minded
people to discuss the show or or just
anything else health and fitness related
that's on your mind check out the
stronger by science Facebook group and
or subreddit uh good folks there and
that's that that's probably the best
place to just get in touch with us
generally
um
so yeah let's let's hop right into it
let's do it
um
so if if you listen to the the last
fireside chat episode you you probably
got a bit of an introduction to Lindsay
already but uh I I shouldn't admit this
since I was previously the host of the
Fireside Chats but not not the main
episodes uh a lot of people skip the
fireside chats we we realize that so
this will be a lot of y'all's uh first
introduction to Lindsay so
um Lindsay Lindsay is my wife uh and she
is also
probably the person who's whose content
you've actually consumed the most of at
Stronger by science even if you didn't
realize it if you follow us on social
media if you get our newsletter any of
that that that's all Lindsay
um she's she's the she's crafting your
words or Eric's words previously into
something it's they're not my words I'm
just editing and kind of finessing them
for the platforms they're being shared
on it just to be just to be fair to
everyone creating content well in the
end they they are they are your ultimate
words okay anyway
um she's she's the person who has been
running the show behind the scenes this
whole time
um
she is she is the reason that Stronger
by science is actually a business and
that I'm not living under a bridge
somewhere
um and she's she's generally excellent
and great and I I think you're gonna
like her a lot and Germaine to this
podcast her her formal background is in
journalism uh she she has a journalism
degree
um you know and and after getting out of
school working in journalism for a while
she was she was ahead of the curve in in
realizing that it is in fact and has
always been the lion fake news media so
she don't know about that she left it
behind for the much more noble world of
uh blogging of blogging of a fitness
vlogging
um
but uh but yeah so
you know we're we're gonna like I said
at the top of the show we're going to
experiment with with the format and
segments a little bit but we kind of
think Lindsay's beat is probably going
to be
kind of like light media criticism
almost like like keeping keeping up with
what is going on in in the media and
health and science journalism more more
mainstream stuff than we typically cover
on the show
um and things that may not be on your
radar but maybe should be because you're
likely to encounter them on social media
or you might hear about them from a
friend or family member and they'll say
like hey what's what's going on with
this and if you're just like all aboard
kind of the evidence-based Fitness
content Universe it may be something
that you're kind of like peripherally
aware of but haven't really dug into
um that that you know for for generally
understanding what's going on in the
industry and what's going on in just
different niches of the fitness industry
uh you you probably you probably should
know about or at minimum stuff you'll
probably find interesting just just
knowing what's going on in in the
broader industry
um so that is that is probably what your
beat is going to be I think so yeah
and I think like well what will be cool
about it is I'll keep my eye on you know
the news articles and what's being
shared on social and stuff and I can
come into these episodes and give a
broad overview of these different topics
and then we can tap into your knowledge
of the research
um which is something that I don't have
experience in it's like reading research
so we can kind of bring those two things
together to present like a really cool
well-rounded overview of different fads
or like weird things being shared around
or just like fun things that we think
the audience is going to find amusing
exactly so
um
you have a segment I do yeah so this is
the first one of those take it away take
it away yeah let's do it so what we're
going to be talking about is uh
vibration plates Greg do you know
anything about vibration plates I know a
little bit about vibration plates uh I I
have some first-hand experience with
them there there is one at the Lifetime
Fitness we go to
and uh I I like it I think it's fun what
do you like to use it for
for for just like generally stretching I
guess yeah
um like a a stretch where it might
otherwise otherwise feel like it takes
20 30 seconds for things to start kind
of relaxing and and loosening up on a
bike on a vibration plate it might take
it like perceptually it feels like it
takes maybe a little less time like 10
15 seconds or something like that
um
and and really more than anything I just
I just think it's fun
um yeah I'm a I'm a novelty seeking
creature and it's like a weird little
sensory experience so that that's that's
mostly why I use it
um but yeah
um
I I do know a reasonable bit about it
but I don't know all of the content you
plan to cover so I don't necessarily
want to scoop you
um but I do know that they're
they're often used and recommended at
least in the clinical world for people
who
um might have like low strength or low
like bone mass bone mineral density and
also might struggle to do more
conventional exercise
um so it's it's a sort of low intensity
thing people can do that doesn't require
them to generate the movement that still
has at least like some of the benefits
of some types of exercise
um so I know that that's generally what
they were developed for and kind of the
the more clinical uses of them but but
I'm less I'm less aware of what people
try to use them for if they're not in
kind of a clinical population right and
there are a lot of people trying to use
them for things that are not in a
clinical population and that's how I
became aware of it is
um I guess it's a skyrocketing thing on
Tick Tock right now now I am deeply
under cool so I don't learn about Tick
Tock Trends from Tick Tock itself but
from newsletters that are talking about
popular things on Tick Tock
um so
that's a little embarrassing but that's
how I learned about it is uh is an
article
um from Beth scorecki at Lifehacker and
yeah so the vibrating plates vary in
size and price there are the ones on
Amazon and these are the ones that like
a lot of the girls on Tick Tock are
using and they're like you know cheap a
hundred dollars or so
and they look like
kind of like scales and you either stand
on them or there I saw videos of people
lying on them people like kneeling on
them lots of just getting crazy with it
and they go up to like seven thousand
dollars so like the one that's at our
gym is kind of the top of the line model
and that one is like thousands and
thousands of dollars and those are the
ones that are probably being used in the
research yeah
um but yeah a lot of people using them
in non-clinical for non-clinical
purposes
um but there are also a lot of different
types
um there's whole body vibration low
intensity vibration and localized
vibration I think the big the big one
that's at our gym is a whole body
vibration one and then just like the
smaller ones that that can't shake you
as hard are the the low intensity ones
yeah
um
but so the the people on Tick Tock and
and why these are getting really popular
right now
are saying that vibration plates can be
used as a means of exercise and to Aid
weight loss hell yeah so
there's actually a gym I found
um whenever I was researching this in
Colorado
that is the entire gym is just full of
vibration plates and all of the
exercises are just people doing various
exercising while standing on seven
thousand dollar pieces of equipment dude
I I want to know where they got the
money for that because it's so expensive
it's expensive to outfit a gym in the
first place but at least like most other
pieces of gym equipment have a
reasonably large footprint so they they
take up space so there's like a finite
amount of just money you can put on the
floor of a gym like dude these these
aren't that big like it had to have been
so expensive to outfit that gym like per
square foot and it's just rows of them
yeah like 30 of these seven thousand
dollar things and then you know only one
person can use it at a time per class so
I have no idea how that's gonna work but
they're trying it that that seemed it
seems like a weird
um a weird piece of gym equipment to go
up to someone and be like hey how many
more sets do you have like can can I
work in it's like that's not gonna work
yeah yeah because because most of the
time people are going to be focused on
the exercise at hand but if you're just
doing just like body weight squats or
whatever like you're you're gonna be
able to make full eye contact you're
going to be able to have a conversation
um
and it's it's also gonna you you don't
have a good excuse to get out of it I
guess because it's like ah well it's
gonna be annoying to change the weights
out like
I I'm just I'm just getting like
apprehension of like theoretical social
anxiety that I would experience like
going to that gym yeah
yeah
and just like talking to somebody while
they're vibrating yeah that feels weird
too
yeah yeah
um I mean like when I use it when you
say something to me and I I respond I
don't think my voice sounds like super
[__] up but I just expect that I'm
going to sound like um
I I don't know if kids still do this I
assume they do this seems like a a fun
kid thing for all generations but just
like totally into a fan yeah yeah
talking through a fan yeah that's that's
how I expect my voice to come out when
when I'm on a vibrating platform yeah
but yeah there's a whole Gem of them
people are really into this right now
um and yeah trying to trying to use it
to to lose fat that's kind of the main
thing that's being pitched and it seems
like they're kind of doing it in a spot
reduction way as well like I saw a video
of a girl like she was lying her stomach
on it and said it was like first spot
reduction of belly fat and then like
line her butt on it and saying it was
gonna help her grow like better glutes
so so it is so it sounds like they're
promoting it as like in everything
Wonder machine yeah if you if you want
if you want to make something smaller
guess what this will make it smaller and
if you want to make something bigger
it'll make it bigger too yeah how does
it know if if it needs to do biggering
things or smallering things who [__]
knows who knows yeah there was an
article that I read that kind of listed
out a lot of the claims and it really is
just literally everything it'll Aid wait
weight loss burn fat improve flexibility
enhanced blood flow reduce muscle
soreness after exercise build strength
and decrease stress hormone cortisol
so that is that's a lot
man if if all of those claims are true
I'm shocked that not everyone already
owns one and that they haven't just
taken everything over which makes me
wonder it makes me wonder not all of
those things are true yeah yeah so Greg
have you seen any of these videos or
heard people talking about this or seen
people using these in the past
you know I I haven't really
um
the these these devices themselves have
popped up like in my social media feeds
but yeah exclusively as ads like the the
manufacturers making them uh are just
like putting putting them in my feed and
saying like hey you you should you
should buy this product that we're
selling I don't know if I've ever come
across any like organic content from
someone who is just like a happy user
and is saying like hey I do this you
should do it too which also who knows
how much of that is paid promotion but
that's true yeah I've never I I I'm I'm
aware of these devices but I've never
seen them in the wild in any way that
even like smells organic like it's all
it has for me at least always just been
like a straightforward ad yeah yeah I
mean it's probably in circles that you
just don't really get content for I am
sure that's true
but uh what would you what would you do
if you saw this Amazon description for
one of them that said it helps your body
process fat 30 times faster than running
um I feel like this is why you're not
saying stuff like this they know that
you're gonna what you're just gonna get
angry
how I mean how do you measure that no
just it it go it goes back to something
more basic than measurement like how are
you operationally defining process fat
like is great question is it diet is it
digestion and absorption is it is it
like pollicis uh is it like actual like
beta oxidation like what what what there
are so many things your body does to
process fat right uh what what what are
they talking about yeah we should ask it
as a question on the Amazon page
see what the manufacturer has to say
uh one of the other things that a lot of
the the listings on uh the sales Pages
for these things claim that it works as
a lymphatic draining machine
which I've been seeing this phrase
everywhere recently and I I do not know
what it means yeah okay so your body has
two circulatory systems basically and
one of them uh everyone knows about and
it's it's your blood you got your veins
arteries capillaries whatever you also
have a a parallel circular yeah like
kind of circulatory system your
lymphatic system which
um I don't it it does a lot of stuff
um the probably two most noteworthy
things is
um so like when you when you eat fat
it's like fat itself isn't water soluble
your blood is mostly water so for for
fat and and things like cholesterol to
get transported around your blood
um it needs to be uh packaged up into
these little things that are water
soluble or at least like aren't going to
separate out so like chylomicrons uh
you're you're in in like HDL LDL like
those lipoproteins are basically like
little storage vessels to transport
stuff around in your blood that
otherwise wouldn't be able to to mix
well with in they wouldn't be they
wouldn't go well in an in an aqueous
solution so when you eat fat your body
instead of absorbing it and sending it
into your bloodstream like it would with
amino acids or carbohydrate it sends it
to your liver via your lymphatic system
where it's then packaged up and can be
released and the bloodstream so that's
one thing your lymphatic system does
um but it's also where like a lot of
like immune cells like that that's I
mean you're you have immune cells in
your blood too obviously but like your
your lymph nodes like they create
lymphatic fluid that has a lot of immune
cells in it and that's kind of like a
primary place where those immune cells
are created and then kind of passed
around the body so that they can get to
where they need to go
um and so the the idea of lymphatic
drainage is is people have this idea
that like if you're if your lymphatic
system gets I guess like quote unquote
backed up oh gosh
um
that can make you like look puffy like I
when people talk about lymphatic
drainage I think they're mostly thinking
about it in terms of like their their
like cheeks or like neck yeah appearing
like puffy and swollen
um because like you you have some
lymphatic tissue there and so when
people do like a lymphatic drainage
massage it's basically just kind of like
a face and neck massage to feel like
you're like pushing that lymphatic fluid
down like out of your face so that it'll
appear less puffy
um that doesn't seem like it would work
I I mean I'll be honest with you I don't
know if that's a thing or not yeah to me
it seems like it's a scam yeah
um
and like yeah if it makes a difference
in appearance it could just generally be
from like stimulating blood flow to the
area
um or who knows I mean maybe maybe it is
actually kind of pushing that lymphatic
fluid down because because that that is
that is a real thing that can happen
like if you're if you're sick like your
lymph nodes get swollen right you can
palpate it like you can feel it like
this those tissues can swell right and
vary in size but I thought there's
really nothing you can do about it I
mean
so I'll I'll admit I have not looked
into claims related to lymphatic yeah
sorry but that is this is just something
that I keep seeing and I was like I'm
gonna make him explain this to me now
that is the Assumption people have when
they make claims about lymphatic range
okay and so I guess they think that
standing on these whole body vibration
things is just going to kind of Wiggle
the fluid
down I I guess I guess
um
yeah that that that strikes me as an
implausible claim but who knows who
knows yeah so
with the all the other claims that
they're making it seems like the main
mechanism that they're proposing is that
it like being on a whole body vibration
plate is going to shake you obviously
and it's going to force your muscles to
contract and relax dozens of times per
second
to me that seems
kind of wild like it doesn't seem like
that would be a thing that could happen
and I don't know if it does happen what
you could actually expect the results to
be what do you think about that
so that is
I I would I would read it as kind of
true okay
um
so
your your muscles contract uh in part
voluntarily and in part involuntarily
and a lot of involuntary like the
involuntary contractions are Reef or
reflexes by and large and those reflex
arcs are mainly
to respond to sort of like
perturbations in what you're
experiencing
um when you need to be able to respond
before your brain would have time to
process something and you to be able to
consciously formulate a muscular
response to whatever you're experiencing
um
and so what what a vibration plate is
doing basically is you have this
platform that's go that is just going up
and down like
just a tiny bit Yeah the the cut off
I've seen in the meta-analyzes for kind
of like is it vibrating a lot or a
little is three I think three
millimeters so if it's going up and down
more than three millimeters they're like
oh that's that's a large amplitude if
it's less than three they're like oh
that's a small amplitude
um
but it's it's essentially like when it's
when it's dropping like when it's going
down
um you're experiencing slightly less
gravitational force than you otherwise
would because it's it's kind of like um
when you're standing in an escalator and
it starts going down like as it's
accelerating downward momentarily you
feel a little bit lighter yeah and then
conversely you get in an elevator and
like right as it starts accelerating up
your your mind
a little bit yeah yeah so it's
it's basically that right but just very
very fast and very very small movements
um I'm just imagining somebody going up
and down on an elevator like thousands
of times trying to get these same
effects oh my God yeah
um but yeah so so that's basically
what's happening yeah and so as a result
the gravitational like the the downward
vertical forces your body is contending
with are slightly less when the platform
is going down and slightly more when the
platform is going up
um so there there's like a a quickly
oscillating uh uh band of force your
your muscles are experiencing and trying
to to maintain like equilibrium
homeostasis balance and whatnot against
um and so I don't think a full
accounting of exactly mechanistically uh
what vibrating plates are doing like I
don't think there's like a full
mechanistic accounting of it but the
current hypothesis is that it's
basically activating little little
reflex arcs
um between the muscles and the spinal
column instead of like having to go all
the way up to the brain to
where it's basically like telling your
muscles like very rapidly like hey Force
commands have changed contract a little
harder ooh Force demands have changed
contract a little less hard and just
yeah just rapidly back and forth over
and over again
um and I've seen that termed the tonic
vibration reflex but it's it's basically
just um
yeah just a re a reflex arc that you're
using repeatedly like multiple times per
second to try to
find the appropriate level of like
muscle Force production to match these
like rapidly oscillating demands
um
and uh
so yeah in kind of the the main Central
motor Drive probably isn't changing much
if any so you could conceptualize that
as like oh your muscles aren't
Contracting 60 times per second there's
it's just one contraction which you
would use to like stand up maintain your
posture whatever
um with just like a little sort of like
like with with reflex arcs kind of like
editing that slightly so it's one
contraction but it's it's getting a
little stronger a little less strong a
little stronger a little less strong due
to the feedback from those reflex arcs
or I guess you could conceptualize it as
like 30 to 60 actual unique different
muscle contractions per second but I I
would kind of go the first round yeah
and it's not something that you're
feeling right like you don't feel like
your muscles are Contracting when you're
standing on one of these or does it or
does it feel like it is doing something
no you just feel like you're vibrating
right yeah okay that's
so it's it's it's it's not something you
would feel I don't think yeah and it's
certainly not something you're like
you're consciously having to contract
your muscles super fast but it's it's
those little reflex arcs that are just
just modulating muscle contractile Force
to respond to the very rapid
perturbations they're feeling and
experiencing yeah yeah cool
yeah so I think
the where where we would want to go from
here is
um going through kind of the history of
these uh these pieces of equipment
because something I found interesting
and why I wanted to talk about this is
when you see the videos of people using
uh the pla the platforms and stuff on
Tick Tock it seems like it's just going
to be a complete scam like but when I
start talking to you about it it seems
like there is research there is actual
actually a purpose for using these in
some contexts and there actually is a
really rich interesting history of
people using whole body vibration in
different ways as well
so let's get into that I think uh let's
let's go over the research after the
history and you can tell us a little bit
about
where these pieces of equipment are
actually useful
um but for now I want to tell you about
the history of vibrate vibration that
sounds great I am so excited I I know
nothing about the history of these
devices they showed up in my awareness
in maybe like 2009 and uh I I do not
know anything that preceded that okay
well it actually started way earlier
than I would have thought with the
ancient Greeks and Romans so obviously
they don't have like these platforms but
people have been finding ways to vibrate
for a long time so they were creating
special carts with irregularly shaped
wheels and then driving the carts over
uneven ground to increase the level of
vibration and they thought that this was
going to speed up the healing process so
it's basically just like you're taking a
super bumpy ride and
if you're ill or if you have an injury
this is what they're making you do I
want I wonder if uh I wonder if there
was just like a guy who really sucked at
making wheels but was like a great
salesman he was just like oh that's
incredible he's like dude I yeah you you
say that I made the worst Wheels you've
ever seen but what if what if they're
actually the best wheels you've ever
seen because not only will they get you
from A to B they'll also cure all of
your mouth heal you yeah yeah so Seneca
even described this practice in some of
his writing saying it was beneficial for
preserving his health hell yeah yeah
um they also did something extremely
wacky which was wrapping saws like the
things that you use to cut things in
cotton fabric and then running them back
and forth over an injury so over an
injured part of your body
using the vibration from a saw running
back and forth
over top of that wound and they thought
that that was beneficial
you know so that it I think that sounds
bad because it's a saw yeah but did
their sauce suck oh I mean well that was
still the Bronze Age so like yeah this
all sucked
um but also like that doesn't seem too
ridiculous I guess yeah because like
there there are little
um
they're like personal massaging devices
I guess that like these aren't popular
anymore but like I remember them from my
childhood where they they were basically
like um
like
plastic uh
okay what whatever so they basically
look like miniature anal beads I guess
where it was just like a plastic thing
with just like little little beads on it
I know what you're talking about yeah
like not large enough beads to like
actually be functional as anal beads or
like that that sort of that's good to
clarify um and you you would just like
put it over your leg and just kind of go
back and forth right and the yeah like
the little bumps like it would apply
different levels of pressure as it went
over the tissue and like feel kind of
nice
um
and I mean like if you wrap a saw in
cloth like that's that's functionally
what it becomes like it's it's not gonna
cut you you know it's it's just going to
it's basically just gonna be little
bumps yeah yeah
um so yeah like I I don't know that that
it's it seems like a a barbaric way to
get about the same effect but they also
uh they didn't have plastic back in the
day so like yeah whatever I guess it's
good it's good to realize that the saws
would be quite a bit different the thing
that I imagine when I think about this
is a relatively sharp saw and somebody
who is using the saw on you and is just
going wild with it and is solving too
hard and the saw starts going through
the cotton fabric no and they don't
realize I'm sure they put and then
they're just cutting your wound yeah
yeah
um yeah no that that
I I think that that was probably less
dangerous than it sounds
it's still funny yeah
um so that's that's like the very start
of recorded history on using vibration
for healing purposes and then we're
going to jump way far forward to uh the
1800s and there's a Russian physician
and inventor called Gustav Zander who
developed an apparatus that used weights
and pulleys to create a vibration That
was supposed to simulate riding a horse
because they thought riding horses was
like a good level of vibration and I
thought that was kind of funny because
people also use vibration plates for
horses now like that is a modern thing
whenever I was Googling around about
this there are like ginormous vibration
plates that horse people will buy for
their their fancy horses because they
think it's going to help the recovery
and also hoof growth nice yeah yeah that
that sounds I hope the horses enjoy it
that that either seems like something
they would love or it would just terrify
them it says it said like in the stuff
that I was reading that it helped the
horses relieve stress but I'm like the
horses can't tell you that yeah how do
you know for sure
yeah and they're just in their little
pens on the vibration plate and the
vibration plate looks like it would kind
of take up the whole pen so it's like
they don't have a choice they're just
standing there vibing I do think I don't
know I do think so I'm completely
talking out my ass here I do not know
that much about horses but that's good I
think they're I think they spook easy
and like they've
like I think if they're stressed you
know about it yeah that's true so either
I think either yeah they either like it
or they're just like they're paralyzed
with fear or they might just be fine
with it you know yeah
um but this guy this this Russian guy
also developed
um the belt exercises that were popular
in the
1900s through like 1930 and then they
got really popular again in the 50s and
60s and it seems like this is a type of
vibration plate that a lot of people
have seen it's like you have
um a belt strapped around your torso and
that is the thing that's vibrating and
it's kind of like vibrating your belly
and so that's another thing that people
thought like for spot reduction they
thought they were gonna like vibrate the
fat off of their torsos interesting yeah
yeah I I clicked on the link I I have
seen those things before right that's
what I figured
um and then in the late 1800s
guess who shows up Dr John Harvey
Kellogg my man hell yeah this guy is
wild you you know you're in for a good
time when John Harvey Kellogg shows up
he's trying everything but so he created
a vibrating wooden chair that he thought
would
um improve circulation and alleviate
constipation but do you want to tell the
listeners what some of the other wacky
things that Kellogg did were yeah so he
was
um
do you remember this right I I remember
he was like in a minority religious sect
but I forget which one it was I think
it's Seventh-day Adventist I was
thinking that's what it was but I didn't
want to accidentally put Seventh-Day
Adventists on blast
um but yeah so he
he he kind of had like two two guiding
lights
um
one was that like any any sort of like
non-procreative sex was like bad for you
and and would like drain your body's
vital Essence
um and also he he was he was one of the
first uh I mean I'm sure he wasn't one
of the first I'm sure this goes back a
very very long way but he was one of the
first like kind of modern
all health is about gut health type of
guys
um so he was like really into enemas and
particularly like yogurt enemas yeah
that's too thick of a substance so it I
I think it was like yogurt cut with
water
um and I I think that he was kind of on
like the gut bacteria tip like ah
there's good bacteria in yogurt so it's
like if you're if you're gonna do an
enema anyways may as well throw some
yogurt in there yeah I actually see
something about this on the history.com
page that I use to learn about the his
use of vibration plates so he was an
advocate of yogurt enemas but his just
regular water enemas he created a system
that pumped 15 quarts of water per
minute oh what
what that sounds unpleasant oh yeah
oh yeah we're we're gonna move right on
from that
um you're the one who brought up the
enemas
you at you
stuff you was up to it was one of the
first things you thought of you okay if
you know that and someone says what
weird stuff was this guy up to that's
the weirdest thing he was up to like you
gotta there's some yeah there was no
world where I wasn't going to bring up
the enemy fair enough
um but anyway yeah so he uh he thought
that like sexual lust and desire and in
particular masturbation was just like
just real bad for you yeah it would [__]
you up real bad
um so Kellogg's breakfast cereal it it
is that Kellogg
um it was intentionally made to be
as Bland as possible because he was
basically working on the assumption that
kind of like all excitement and arousal
kind of stemmed from the same source and
so if you ate food that excited you too
much that would also like sexually
excite you too much so like I think he
was just telling on himself there I mean
he he very well may have been
um but yeah so he he founded uh the
Battle Creek sanitarium in Battle Creek
Michigan and a lot of kind of like High
Society people who were feeling like
they they were in a funk uh not stoked
about City Life feeling low energy they
would go to the sanitarium and just have
a bunch of weird stuff shot up their
butt and eat the worst Food possible
yeah uh and and do a bunch of like low
to moderate intensity exercise for like
two weeks yeah and then go back to the
city and say damn I'm feeling good yeah
well one of the things they could do is
to sit on this vibrating wooden chair
that
that look I that feels like it's kind of
antithetical to the whole like don't
don't get aroused type of deal that's
what I'm saying I mean one of the things
he's supposed
to vibration chairs
vital organs
I I I'm sure they did
um he may have not fought quite
expansively enough about which organs it
would stimulate right well in this
article I also saw that one of his
treatments for if you were if you were
having thoughts of masturbation was to
literally put a cage on your dick so
maybe you were sitting on the wooden
chair with like with a little cage
strapped onto you which makes it even
more unpleasant yeah that's not that's
not great
um
yeah so I'm I'm not even going to touch
that I I know I know entirely too much
about like the weird [__] John Harvey
Kellogg did in attempts to stop people
from masturbating and that it gets much
darker yeah that honestly is one of the
Tamer ones exactly that's that's why I
brought this one up yeah it's it's
pretty grotesque yeah
um but back to the vibration plates he
also created a steam-powered version
um that was like a seat for five people
so you and your boys could do it
together hell yeah
that rocks
yeah
um and I just threw in a couple other
things here about other treatments you
could get at the spa
um including a beating and slapping
machine which gave patients the choice
of being pounded or flogged and the
purpose of that was just to stimulate
circulation which I feel like there are
much better ways to stimulate
circulation than having a machine flog
you yeah go go for a walk yeah take a
jaw let's go for a walk yeah Jesus
Christ yeah oh man so yeah I was
delighted that John Harvey Kellogg had
something to do with this and we could
talk about him a little bit but
unfortunately it's time to move on oh no
okay so the rest of this is is much more
tame but in the rest of the 1800s there
was a type of vibration therapy that was
developed for treatment of Parkinson's
disease and it seems like uh researchers
still
um do studies about this so it's kind of
cool that they started picking up on
that 200 years ago and have been
investigating it since then I think
maybe you'll talk about that a little
bit later yeah
um and then in the 1900s scientists in
the Russian Space Program started using
vibration therapy to help strengthen
astronauts bone mass and muscles and
NASA continues to use vibration therapy
to help prevent bone loss to this day
nice
um and then uh after they had the
success during the space program the
Russians started using this on their
Olympic team
um and I think this is the first
indication of it being used for athletic
Pursuits and then in the 1990s uh Gus
Vandermeer a Dutch Olympic team trainer
developed the power plate and this is
like the big vibration place this is the
one that's at our gym this is the one
that the Colorado gym has like 30 of
um so yeah it's this Dutch guy in the
1990s Who develops it for Olympic
athletes in the Netherlands
um and that gets us to today that's
that's the history of vibration so all
the way back to ancient Greeks and
Romans using this for healing purposes
and then in the 90s started using it for
um athletic purposes and now
the girl is on Tick Tock laying on
little vibration plates nice hell yeah
um yeah so the the I the idea of of
people getting into this as kind of like
a miracle cure
um
or kind if it feels like it they're
they're approaching it almost as like an
exercise hack like it won't get you all
the benefits of exercise without having
to write any effort into and they're
doing it for like hours at a time oh
that's which is not good
that yeah oh man yeah if I would have
known they were doing that I would have
looked into this more because I kind I
don't so when I was looking through the
research on this I didn't encounter that
much about like ultra high dose
vibration
hmm well I think that it's definitely
abnormal for somebody to be doing it
yeah for two hours a day but there
definitely are kind of the influencers
saying that they they do it for that
long I think most people who are using
it are using it because they are trying
to kind of use it as a hack for exercise
and I imagine that if you if you feel
like you're really busy and you don't
have time to exercise you're probably
not spending two hours just like lying
down on a plate yeah
um but yeah I I did want to note that
some people do use it for hours at a
time and
vibrating yourself for hours on end is
probably harmful it seems like most of
the research that's been done on stuff
like this is people who
the research that's been done on like
the harmful effects of vibrations is
people who work
um like in construction jobs or
something so it's like occupational
hazards yeah and obviously that can have
a lot of negative effects that's what I
was thinking yeah I was like as the
frequency is the amplitude different
enough to matter because I mean for uh
like the the orthopedic outcomes for
like a jackhammer operations really not
good yeah
um and even like long-haul truckers I
think have a elevated risk of like
spinal disc injuries because you're in a
spine flexed posture and yeah the truck
vibrates more than like most automobiles
would
um so yeah like I I didn't want to like
well I wasn't playing planning on like
directly bringing those things up but
that's the first place my brain went
yeah they're standing on them for two
hours because I'm like ah those types of
vibrations may be enough different that
it wouldn't generalize but like I don't
I don't know how I feel about that right
um
but yeah yeah so so research stuff
the
the general tenor of the research so so
one like one thing just to start with
with this body of research when you said
that you were doing this topic
um
I I will admit I had not looked into the
research on on whole body vibration uh
much at all I mean like a paper or two
would come up in the journal suite for
Mass from time to time but this is never
a topic of research that I had done a
deep dive into yeah and when I started I
discovered something
interesting which is that this is one of
those fun little bodies of research
where where it feels like there are like
three meta-analyzes per like piece of
original research that's been done
like if you just if you just PubMed
search whole body vibration
meta-analysis you're gonna get a lot of
results and like I think there are
probably more pieces of primary research
than review articles but like it's it's
very close and generally it's it's not
that close which I don't know what's
causing that but it's it's convenient
for me because I would rather just kind
of like skim a dozen reviews than have
to skim 60 individual papers so it was
good for getting my feet wet nice
um
and what I found basically
is that in a extremely small scale way
vibration plates do seem like they mimic
some of the benefits of exercise
in that standing on a vibration plate
requires a little more muscular effort
than just standing on not a vibration
plate that makes sense doing light body
weight exercise on a vibration plate
since you're like activating those
spinal reflex arcs over and over it's a
little more challenging than doing a
similar exercise not on a vibration
plate
um
and it also seems like the kind of like
high frequency stimulation and the
activation of those res of those reflex
arcs might be helpful for some people
with like neurological conditions that
might struggle with kind of the central
motor Drive yeah and keeping their
muscles working well so it's like you
imagine Parkinson's
um
and it also seems to
potentially be particularly useful for
like analgesic effects of exercise so
analgesic means like pain relieving and
there there was a meta on people with
like knee osteoarthritis and it it
seemed like
um
for just like reducing pain a little bit
that that vibration plates maybe
um so so like all exercise has I don't
want to say all exercise in general for
the most part has analgesic effects yeah
and like is beneficial for people with
OA or just like other kind of pain
conditions
um and so there's like some suggestion
that maybe vibration plates are like a
little bit better than normal exercise
for that stuff
um because it helps kind of like
desensitize some like other reflex arcs
that may be like driving some of the the
pain perception or it could just be that
um it's a it's a different enough
Sensation that it kind of like
that like if if you have chronic pain
some of the pain you experience might be
due to the expectation of pain when you
do something right and so like just just
since it changes the sensations you're
experiencing it straps your brain a
little bit yeah yeah yeah
um
I'll see I like it it might be kind of
helpful for that
um but yeah like that that's basically
the lay of the land
um so it for the most part for for
people without neurological conditions
or uh like OA or like chronic pain
conditions or anything like that
it basically seems like a way to make
easy exercise ever so slightly harder
um
and so for outcomes like like strength
outcomes for for instance or like there
have been a few studies looking at
changes in vertical jump height
what you generally see is that in
studies where you
where you test vibration plates on like
high-level athletes and people who are
already like quite good at whatever
skill you're going to test it doesn't
really seem like they do too much yeah
um whereas if it's a population where
say just body weight squats would would
be sufficiently intense to have a
positive training stimulus and like
cause strength or or jump height or like
explosiveness type adaptations
the slight elevation and intensity from
the vibration plates and I mean there
there might also be just some motor
learning effects from like activating
those reflex arcs and like kind almost
like greasing the groove a little bit
um and like making like getting you
maybe a little bit better at activating
those muscles like there was another
meta on uh they termed it neuromuscular
activation but it was just like like
surface EMG type data
um so I get may be helpful for that so
basically like if you're
you're if you're like basically
untrained and doing like sets of 10 body
weight squats on the ground would be
good for you doing sets of tin body
weight squats on a vibration plate might
be like slightly better for you than the
10 body weight squats on the ground yeah
but if you're someone who would need to
do say 10 squats with 400 pounds to
actually cause some sort of a beneficial
effect doing those body weight squats on
a vibration plate probably isn't going
to do anything particularly useful for
you definitely so it it seems like
like kind of
kind of useful for clinical populations
yeah in elderly populations yeah
um oh yeah yeah so I didn't even mention
that
um so there there have been quite a few
studies looking at this in elderly
populations and it seems like it may
help with uh like preservation of bone
mineral density a little bit that that
one is kind of up in the air like there
have been like three or four metas on
this like I said entirely too many
meta-analyzes in this area and depending
on like what aspect of bone mineral
density they're looking at like or are
we looking at the trochanter are we
looking at the spine or are we looking
at like whole body measures
um and just like the inclusion exclusion
criteria for the studies it's just kind
of a coin flip about whether they're
gonna see like a small statistically
significant effect or a small not
statistically significant effect but it
seems like it has kind of a a possibly
beneficial effect on bone mineral
density yes that's trivial to small in
magnitude
um and it also seems to help with like
balance and maybe fall prevention in
elderly people as well which which also
goes back to those reflex arcs like
um there are a lot of reasons that that
falls increase with age but one of them
is like your your reflexes get less
reflexy
um and so yeah just just keeping keeping
them a little a little more kind of like
honed than they would be otherwise yeah
so yeah kind of useful for old people
kind of useful for uh people with like
certain neurological conditions and sort
of useful for untrained folks
um prop probably not particularly useful
for people listening to this podcast
except for people who might be dealing
with some sort of chronic pain
do you know if the research where they
found it being useful for some of those
populations if they were using the whole
body vibration or if it was like lower
intensity vibration
I I think it was mostly whole body
vibration yeah
um
yeah when when you said you were looking
at whole body vibration I'll admit I
didn't look at research on local or
lower intensity vibration gotcha at all
yeah
all right all right
um oh did you I so I thought you were
going to say one more thing about uh
people using it for fat loss
um but
I can just go ahead and say what I what
I had highlighted sure to mention about
that in particular okay so you you said
that the the tick tock girls are using
it to promote fat loss yes all right so
this is one of those things where
um
they are
directionally correct but but
practically far off base
so it does it does take a little more
energy to do anything on a vibration
plate than it would on non-vibrating
ground
um so energy expenditure and therefore
fat oxidation is ever so slightly higher
than than it would be otherwise but the
impact itself is extremely trivial so
this is from a a meta-analysis on on the
topic and there have been two and both
of them were very funny because they
um
they both found uh so comparing whole
body vibration to either like control or
like similar exercise without whole body
vibration both of them found a
statistically significant impact like
like beneficial effect of
uh whole body vibration platforms on fat
loss but both of them made it extremely
clear that like yes we found a
statistically significant effect but it
is not clinically meaningful yeah it's a
it's it's nothing like we there are a
handful of studies the effect they saw
was very consistent so therefore like we
had we had the power to detect to this
small effect well we're talking like
over uh like 12 to 24 week intervention
like one additional kilo of fat loss
like that that's the sort of effect
magnitude that you're dealing with and
so yeah these these meta analysts were
just like this is a significant effect
but don't take it seriously like don't
don't take this and run with it
significant doesn't always mean
meaningful and uh it's it seems like
people didn't entirely get the memo yeah
um somebody must have pulled that and
yeah started spreading it yeah because I
mean they they can say like yeah a
meta-analysis found that this this
increases fat loss because like it does
but again probably not to an extent that
actually matters and so here here's like
a fun a fun quote from one of these
papers
um
despite the increased energy consumption
and oxidation of fat writvegger from
2010 stated that a person weighing 70
kilos while performing whole body
vibration would assume would consume
approximately 20 liters per hour of
oxygen assuming an energy equivalent of
20.9 kilojoules per liter of oxygen and
a caloric equivalent of 39 kilojoules
per gram of fat that would imply a
weight loss of 10 grams of fat per hour
thus it is reasonable to conclude that
this type of exercise produces no loss
in fat mass as the duration of whole
body vibration is insufficient to elicit
the desired reduction in body fat so
basically like for for Americans
listening to this there's like what 454
grams in a pound so if you're oxidizing
an additional 10 grams of fat per hour
on one of these you would need to spend
45 hours on one to burn one additional
pound of fat oh gosh so and don't do
that yeah so the the tick tock girlies
are not wrong in that it does it does
technically have an effect but it is an
effect that is so small and would take
so long to actually manifest to
a measurable degree that uh yeah just
like going for a walk would be
definitely way better yeah let's go for
a walk yep
so that that does it that does it yeah
my first segment vibration plates now we
know they are useful for some things and
some populations but don't buy one just
to lie on it on the floor
especially for Seven Grand like you can
oh yeah you can have way more fun with
with seven Grand doing just about
anything yeah yeah but
maybe if there's one at your gym hop on
it try stretching Greg seems to like it
yeah I do like it like it's it's fun it
feels nice
um but I I would not drop that money to
buy one for the house definitely
um okay well if anybody has any ideas
for or if you want to hear me talk about
any other trends that you've seen or
articles that you're wondering about or
that your friends and family are asking
you about and you want our take then let
us know and I'm excited to do more
segments like this yeah and you can use
that email address podcast Stronger by
science.com for that as well if there's
a a topic in in the media uh or just
that the tick tock girlies or just some
other uh a branch or click of the
fitness industry that we probably the
pros are doing closely yeah let us know
let us know what what you'd like to see
us cover
laughs
all right let's let's shift gears to my
segment okay that's cool with you let's
do it all right so
um
I'm talking about uh
exercise during pregnancy
um covering content very similar to a a
research Spotlight back in April
and um so yeah Lin's when when you think
about exercise in pregnancy like what
what comes to mind for you like what
what sorts of exercise do you think
would or wouldn't be a good idea and and
more importantly whatever ideas you have
about exercise in pregnancy where do you
think those are where do you think those
ideas came from yeah so
I think generally
I think that
exercise during pregnancy seems like a
good thing to do I know that most people
are encouraged to maintain a certain
level of physical activity during
pregnancy for the health of themselves
and for the baby
um in terms of things that feel
safe or not safe for like a good idea or
not
um I don't know I've been around I think
I've been around since I've been around
Lifting for so long I've been around
pregnant women lifting and so it doesn't
freak me out in the way that I it seems
to freak A lot of people out I think in
terms of lifting
maybe bench press seems kind of weird
um and I I just think that that's like
oh yikes don't drop that on your belly
obviously most people shouldn't be
dropping the bar on them at any point
though but that's that's really the only
like lifting activity I can think of
that if I saw like an extremely pregnant
person doing it would make me nervous
um probably like super heavy squats or
something too yeah
um just like any degree of like really
straining pretty hard when you're
pregnant yeah it seems maybe not great
um and then outside of lifting
hmm
fighting Sports don't do that well yeah
it's it's not fair like you're you're
you're bringing a tag team into a solo
match like you have two people fighting
one person like obviously pregnant women
shouldn't do fight Sports they would
dominate
that's not what I was thinking about
you're totally right
you have double the strength when you're
pregnant and you're gonna [__] somebody
up uh you probably shouldn't like
climb K2 or Everest or something do
anything that's gonna impact like oxygen
levels that feels bad that feels
generalizable though yeah you definitely
we can just leave it at don't climb
Everest there's so many people who got
lost there this year like they're just
missing yeah don't just don't just don't
do it also don't go down looking for the
Titanic like similar thing just don't
just stop taking these risks yeah yeah I
I agree with that wholeheartedly
yeah so pregnant women probably
shouldn't be deep under the ocean either
yeah
another thing that's like impacting
oxygen or like yeah how your body is
functioning okay
um but other than that like
I feel like most exercise probably a
good idea during pregnancy and I think
I don't think I really had many
um
I don't think I really thought about
this until
I was already kind of into lifting and
we were together so I I don't think I
really ever had an opportunity to
develop
preconceived notions of like the danger
of lifting while pregnant or anything
like that I've always kind of assumed
that
it was fine okay um I've seen lots of
pregnant people squatting deadlifting
and they seem to they seem to be doing
fine sweet yeah yeah
um so there there is I think still a lot
of fear and concern definitely about
exercise yeah I mean if you're see like
the brave souls who pose videos of
themselves on Instagram squatting while
pregnant people are [__] terrible in
the comments section like it's obvious
that there is like so much stigma and
like people are going to be telling you
what to do if they see you doing that
and telling you that you're doing it
wrong and telling you that you're gonna
hurt your baby and hurt yourself yeah
dude one of my favorite types of types
of comments there is
um people people commenting on a video
of a pregnant woman like lifting heavy
and being like ah like straining like
that is gonna like it's it's gonna cause
infertility it's like what it's like
brother they're pregnant like the the
proof's in the pudding like like check
the scoreboard like they're like at
least somewhat fertile yeah there there
was um
there was a belief for a long time that
intense exercise would cause infertility
um which yeah like even if that's
something you believe saying that to a
person who's currently pregnant it's
just like that that doesn't seem to be
the person to say that right
um but yeah so there is still out there
a lot of apprehension about exercise
during pregnancy and especially like
intense exercise during pregnancy and uh
a lot of that actually comes from the
Victorian era
um which was kind of like
like
early to mid 1800s to like early 1900s
thereabouts so like kind of like middle
to late 1800s was kind of the the height
of that era
um sort of like John Harvey Kellogg
actually like he was he was a Victorian
era man
um doing some wild [__] yeah they were
doing wild [__] and Victor Victorian era
yeah and it was
um during that period it was a
a fashionable opinion to hold that
exercise in general was bad and that
exercise for pregnant people in
particular was like especially bad
um was that like the heart the heartbeat
thing yeah it was it was like a pseudo a
pseudo-scientific thing so so kind of
like when when epidemiology was like
kind of in its infancy and you and I
think people were already aware that the
correlation doesn't necessarily imply
causation but I don't think it had been
like internalized culturally to to the
extent that it should have been yeah
um people weren't shouting at it at each
other like they are now yeah and so
there there was a lot of just like
observational stuff where it's like hey
look the the idol Rich tend to live kind
of a long time and the the laborers who
are out there like getting in a lot of
physical activity and making their
living from the sweat of their brow they
they tend to have life lives that at
that time were still nasty brutish and
short
um yeah and so it's like oh yeah like uh
there there was kind of the idea that
the body was almost like a battery yeah
and that uh you just kind of had a fixed
number of heartbeats yeah or a fixed
amount of like vital energy and you once
you expended it bada bing bada boom
that's it you're gonna die had nothing
to do with like wealth differences or
privilege or anything like that or like
just like access to like nutritious food
in a period where like people are still
getting richers yeah yeah uh yeah yeah
before we like fully dealt with scurvy
uh they're like oh no it's because
they're exercising too much yeah yeah so
um yeah that was that Mo like most of
the apprehension we have today still
like just comes from the Victorian era
because before that and after that
um it's mostly people being like Oh yeah
like exercise is fine and during that
during that one era when
um
it it cut like it kind of dovetailed
with mass media I guess because like
that's when that's when like the penny
papers were were a big thing and and you
could for the first time like
disseminate ideas like very broadly like
the printing press had been around for a
while but like printed stuff was
expensive because like paper was
expensive they didn't have like the
cheap pulp paper
um
and yeah so it was it was one of the
first times that like you could one get
a glimpse into how people lived kind of
across the socio-economic strata instead
of just kind of the rich people hanging
out with the rich people the Poor's
hanging out with the pores like there
there was kind of more awareness of what
was going on and it was just easier to
like disseminate ideas easier so I'm I'm
sure that like Rich [__] a long time
ago were just like oh yes our Idol lives
are better than that of the poor yeah
convenient but like they they also
didn't have a good way to like tell the
pores that like oh yeah what you're
doing is [__] yep
um so you don't have a choice anyways
right yeah so um
yeah yeah so that the the idea and
certainly like the popularization of the
idea the exercise in pregnancy is like
bad and dangerous that that
Lord like what we experience of that
today largely just came from that era
but going back before that
um exercise during pregnancy was
generally seen and considered to be a
good thing so
um so I I'm gonna I'm gonna cite a
couple papers uh in in the show notes to
kind of go through some of this
historical stuff
um one of them is by Miriam Katz
exercise activity during pregnancy past
and present and the other is uh by by
downs and colleagues physical activity
and pregnancy past and present evidence
and future recommendations so I'm going
to be quoting from from those two papers
during this during this historical
segment a little bit
um
but yeah so so both Aristotle and uh
Plutarch
um urged Greek women to exercise to
decrease pain during childbearing
um which which is something we now know
to be true women who exercise I don't
know if it decreases pain but it
definitely
it increases it increases your odds of
not having to have a C-section right it
also like speeds up later exactly quite
a bit yeah
um and even up until the 18th century uh
so like the 1700s so so pre-victorian
era
um maternal physical activity was still
generally viewed favorably
um because people believed and
rightfully so that it tended to result
in easier labor and also reduced fetal
size
um like the the babies a little bit
smaller a little bit easier to get out
um and and that that is still true like
you really yeah so there there's like a
like not big like two to four hundred
gram lower fetal birth rate birth weight
um women who who exercised during
pregnancy versus not
um and and that was so that was actually
something that was kind of flipped on
its head again during the Victorian era
it was kind of assumed that like larger
fetuses were better like it might make
for a tougher delivery right but they're
like a big strong baby well that like
they're there was uh I mean they they
found Association so like this is
um
this is correlated with like lower rates
of like infant mortality like the the
bigger babies tend to live better but it
was mostly the bigger babies were born
into Rich families with Idol moms yeah
yeah have access to better nutrition
right so the babies could just get
bigger yeah in the medical practice that
that existed of the day
um
but yeah yeah so
um yeah even uh like from from [__]
Aristotle until the 18th century it was
like okay okay like maternal physical
activity is generally pretty good nice
although by the 18th century they were
they were recommending uh maybe no
dancing and maybe no horseback riding
while while you're pregnant which yeah
horseback riding does seem weird to do
while pregnant also I don't think that
was
uh pregnancy thing I think that was a
like puritanical type of thing uh yeah
anyway whatever uh they're like that's a
lewd thing to do yeah you're a pregnant
woman have some respect yeah but for for
the most part they're they're like oh
yeah like be active during pregnancy
that that's cool that's good uh then the
Victorian era hit and it's like oh no
like you you should be as sedentary as
possible like like the rich who are more
likely to have healthy babies
um
and uh one one final thing to note
before I get off of the like
like pre-victorian historical stuff in a
couple of the articles I read
um like talking about the the history of
exercise recommendations during
pregnancy something something I saw
brought up multiple times were people
saying that like the earliest reference
to like the earliest written reference
we have to to exercise improving
um like pregnancy outcomes was from the
Bible in the book of of Exodus damn and
um
as best I can tell so one like just
spoiler alert
um that's that's not that's not a thing
like there's not there's not a Bible
passage that really supports this do you
read the whole book of Exodus last night
to make sure uh no but I did read the
surroundings context for for the verse
being cited
um but the the citation for this claim
that that like
the the biblical writer saying that yeah
that exercise is good during pregnancy
as best I can tell it it just goes back
to a single citation
um a paper by Burnett uh title is value
of prenatal exercise uh in the British
Journal of Obstetrics and Gynecology
from 1956. okay and uh the the author of
that article claimed that the writer of
Exodus said that slave women had an
easier time in childbirth than the the
like Hebrew slave women had a easier
time in childbirth than the rich lazy
Egyptian women and uh Lindsay as as a
graduate of a Christian University does
does that ring a bell for you no but I
also did not pay close attention in my
old testament class okay well you paid
close attention in your Old Testament
class though so
does a ring a bell for you it also
doesn't ring a bell okay great and and
like I said that's because this is one
one of the worst biblical
interpretations I've seen which like I
kind of expect from like uh like
Christian influencers on social media
yeah you don't expect it from a medical
journal but uh that's that's what we
have here so the the verse being cited
is Exodus 119. would you mind would you
mind reading that for the people from
The New International Version
sure the midwives answered Pharaoh
Hebrew women are not like Egyptian women
they are vigorous and give birth before
the midwives arrive all right so that
that was the single verse quoted to
support the claim that like yes even the
biblical writer knows that like these
these hearty slave women they they give
birth faster because they're uh they're
more physically active so Lins would
would you mind reading a bit of the
surrounding context as well so I I can
do this if you don't want to no I can do
it okay so this is this is Exodus 1 15
through did not expect to be reading
verses today
the king of Egypt said to the Hebrew
midwives whose names were oh
help me out here we're gonna go with
sifra and Pua
okay what we're helping the Hebrew women
during childbirth on the delivery stool
they can see that the baby is a boy kill
him but if it is a girl let her live The
Midwives however feared God and did not
do what the king of Egypt had told them
to do they let the boys live then the
king of Egypt summoned The Midwives and
asked them why have you done this why
have you let the boys live The Midwives
answered Pharaoh Heber women are not
like Egyptian women they are vigorous
and give birth before the midwives
arrive so God was kind to The Midwives
and the people increased and became even
more numerous and because the midwives
feared God he gave them families of
their own alright so that that's that
verse in the surrounding context
um
so I mean
The Midwives just lied to Pharaoh like
that's that's what's going down in verse
19. uh they're they're this passage
doesn't provide any evidence that the
Hebrew women yeah actually we weren't
there yeah we weren't even there yeah
yeah
um
and and also like I highly doubt that
kind of typical Egyptian women is like
over 3000 years ago were just living a
life of luxury like that
doesn't really seem to track yeah they
have [__] to do yeah so I mean the
yeah so that this was not some sort of
like scientific claim that uh that the
Hebrew women did actually give birth
faster because because they were more
physically active during pregnancy than
the Egyptians bizarre to include is this
in a scientific paper it's too it's too
midwives just lying to Pharaoh about why
they weren't killing babies like they
were right commanded to do
um
anyway yeah so uh that that's that's the
historical context I guess with with a
with a little diversion uh into the
Bible so post-victorian era
um which yeah kind of ended with World
War one we get into the 1920s and this
is when people started like recommending
women be more active but they were
starting from that Victorian Baseline of
just like hey don't don't do anything
from kind of the 1920s onward we see
this slow progression of like ah you can
you can do a little more oh okay that's
going fine you can do a little more than
that yeah um so so you saw like the
first
kind of I guess like early gyms like
Things Catering to to pregnant women to
exercise popping up in the 20s and 30s
um but then the the government got
involved I think for the first time in
1949 with uh the U.S Children's Bureau
uh issuing a recommendation for prenatal
physical activity saying that in the
absence of maternal complications
pregnant women can continue housework
gardening and daily walks and even swim
occasionally and for the daily walks
it's uh up up to one mile but to break
it up into several short bouts which
we look at that yeah what what is your
thought reading I mean that's just
that's not a lot of walking right
um yeah so it's it's basically saying
like hey this you're gonna walk that
much just like walking around your house
or if they have other kids they're
chasing around
but so it's it's basically saying like
hey look this this is the post-war era
um you know women get back out of the
factories get back into the homes yeah
you can do your house yeah your
housewife [__] and like maybe walk a
little bit
um yeah and that's that's about it which
don't go too far which we look back now
and we're like whoa that's extremely
restrictive but yeah but for the time
like this this was the first government
guideline saying like hey women like you
you actually can and should be a little
active during pregnancy and not just you
know be in the bed as much as possible
yeah
um
then moving on into the 70s and 80s you
see more just kind of like General
recommendations for quote moderate
physical activity
um
and most of them were kind of like
focused on improving maternal Fitness
and going all the way back to Aristotle
easing uh labor and delivery
um and then in 1985 uh ACOG the American
College of Obstetricians and
gynecologists issued their first
guidelines for prenatal physical
activity
um and they basically said that like hey
most most like moderate intensity
aerobic stuff is fine but you should
maybe be a little careful with high
impact activities which uh you know
we're not talking like skydiving by by
high impact they mean like running
because like there's the impact of each
footfall so like you know you can walk
you can cycle you can swim maybe be
careful with running that might still be
a little bit too much impact okay
um and if you run don't go more than
like 15 minutes at a time and still at a
at just a moderate intensity don't get
your heart rate over 140 beats per
minute and and make sure your core
temperature doesn't get elevated too
much so that's still like quite a bit
more restrictive than the guidelines
today but we're seeing like a big step
in the right direction from from what
people were saying in 1949
then in 2002 ACOG had another updated
guideline that is now instead of saying
like you can do most of this stuff
they're actually recommending that women
be active uh during pregnancy
um so they they're recommending 30
minutes of moderate intensity physical
activities most days uh for pregnant
women without medical or obstetric
complications and they also
instead of saying like hey some of this
aerobic stuff is fine but like running
that might be kind of dangerous that
they gave like a much a much broader
range of activities that saying like ah
yeah most most of this stuff is safe
um so that was 2002 and then in 2008 we
see
um the the first recommendation for uh
actually allowing any vigorous intensity
physical activity at all so up to this
point it had all been low to moderate
intensity yeah the 2008 recommendation
recommended uh at least 150 minutes of
moderate intensity physical activity per
week for pregnant women again without
obstetric or medical complications uh
and these recommendations for the first
time put guidelines in place for
vigorous intensity physical activity
um and those those recommendations were
essentially like if you were already
engaging safely in vigorous exercise
before pregnancy you can keep doing that
um you want to monitor it closely talk
to your doctor but like if you're
already running pretty hard yeah you're
already in that good shape yeah you can
you can keep doing that but you you
probably shouldn't if you haven't been
doing vigorous physical activity before
or if you're gonna start you need to be
like super super careful about it
um makes sense to me just yeah yeah for
sure so
you know the
that's
by 2008 we're getting guidelines that
look pretty similar to what we have
today but that was a long process like
from basically the the 1920s up to
2008. yeah there there it was like hey
don't if you're gonna walk cap it at a
mile and break it into little chunks to
like hey if you were already doing
vigorous exercise before you can you can
keep with it yeah it took from yeah like
the 1920s to 2008 to get that far I mean
that sounds like a long time but I'm
actually struck by like the all the
increments within that and what it would
be like kind of generationally each time
where you know if you're pregnant your
mom and your grandma are going to have
totally different ideas of like what
you're supposed to do when you're
pregnant and are going to tell you that
and are going to tell you that you're
doing things wrong
um because it is like really a huge
shift each generation and and what
they're telling you is probably stuff
they heard from their doctor exactly
yeah just reflecting the guidelines
right yeah
um so the the most recent uh ACOG
guidelines were published in 2020 and
they were just reaffirmed earlier this
year and just kind of like the the tldr
is like most stuff is on the table
um
so we'll we'll link the American College
of obstetrician and gynecologists
exercise recommendations in in the show
notes if you if you really want to dig
into this for yourself either because
you're you're pregnant planning to
become pregnant or train a lot of
pregnant people
um we're not going to go through them in
depth here but kind of the broad Strokes
is like
yeah like most most stuff is fine
um with a few exceptions so the current
guidelines are still pretty leery about
vigorous intensity exercise for people
who aren't already accustomed to it and
then just kind of like some edge cases
which like you you actually brought up
like quite a few of these uh when I
asked you about this just at the start
of this uh this segment but um they say
that that pregnant women shouldn't scuba
dive uh because there is the inability
of the fetal of fetal pulmonary
circulation to filter uh bubble forming
that makes sense yeah
um does not evolve scuba diving correct
yeah what so um
yeah never mind we're not going to get
into gas kinetics yeah let's not do that
um but but yeah and then going the
opposite direction low pressure it's um
they're still like kind of leery about
exercise at altitude for women who live
close to sea level although if you live
at altitude it's like ah you can you can
keep doing what you were doing that was
going fine before but like so like if
you went to if you're Denver if you're
from Miami and go to Denver it's like ah
maybe interesting little careful okay
um but that was kind of more couched in
terms of like
we so we'll as we'll see like these
recommendations are like intentionally
conservative they're they're not they're
not gonna wreck they're not going to
recommend anything unless they're very
very confident it's okay yeah and for
for the exercise at altitude there they
were just like well it's it seems fine
for women who already live at altitude
there are certainly like reports of
women who live close to sea level going
to altitude going for a hike and being
fine but like we don't have enough
controlled data on this to be like
really complex that makes sense yeah
um and there there are still also
concerns about exercise in the heat
especially uh long duration or high
intensity because dude exercise in the
Heat and um especially if you had a
dehydration component to it right that
that puts
that that like taxes uh your circulatory
system like crazy yeah because like
you're you're needing to maintain blood
flow to the brain to maintain
Consciousness you're needing to maintain
blood flow to the muscles to actually
keep moving keep exercising you're
needing to maintain blood flow to the
skin uh for thermoregulation and
sweating
um and uh yeah and if you're pregnant
you also need to maintain blood flow to
the fetus as well yeah and so even take
the fetus out of the equation and
managing all of that blood flow and
oxygen delivery during exercise in the
heat is a is a large challenge to
everyone right so add a fetus into the
mix [__] gets dicey yeah
um and and also uh I'm pretty sure that
if your first trimester and maybe you
don't even know you're pregnant yet
getting overheated can cause neural tube
defects no yikes so yeah like it you you
want to be careful with the heat yeah
um
so yeah that's uh those those are some
of the things that that ACOG still
expresses some some trepidation about
does make sense too and for our purposes
here there are three more that are
relevant to lifters and that is very
heavy resistance training uh supine
resistance training or supine exercise
in general so that's exercise where
you're laying on your back oh yeah and
uh the valsalva maneuver so
um why do you think those three things
might be something that that there would
be recommendations against or at least I
caution with
yeah so supine
I mean I said bench pressing is one of
the things it I I don't know maybe just
dropping things on your belly okay I
don't know I don't know what else what
are what are other supine exercises uh
like hip thrusts
okay or like loot Bridges
um leg raises
um
like even sit-ups I guess at least for
yeah the while you're down part of it
um
I don't know like Peck flies I guess
like dumbbell Peck flies I mean they're
yeah I'm really not sure I don't know
yeah you do most exercises like standing
or something definitely there are a few
you doing yeah so I'm not sure why they
would recommend against that in that
case for like valsalva and heavy
resistance training I'm guessing it's
just like uh like blood pressure related
yeah and just like
uh uh the intra-abdominal pressure that
you have to have for belsava or if
you're you know doing a like picking up
a heavy squat bar off the rack or
something like
and also just you know you don't want to
fail a lift probably
and you don't want to get like
light-headed and potentially pass out or
something yeah
so for for valsalva you nailed it for
Supine and heavy resistance training
there there are a couple other
considerations
um so yeah the
both heavy resistance training and the
valsalva maneuver are cautioned against
due to concerns about the very large
increase in blood pressure that can
occur when you're like really really
straining and especially really
straining while doing the valsalvan yeah
um generally with exercise what you tend
to see is systolic blood pressure goes
up diastolic blood pressure stays
like pretty flat like maybe Elevate
slightly but not a ton with resistance
training you get an increase in
diastolic as well
um which can be further exacerbated with
an increase in intra-abdominal pressure
doing the valsalva maneuver and
basically like your your systolic blood
pressure can get really high if you're
going on a hard run but like diastolic
stays kind of low and and they know that
kind of those blood pressure kinetics
the the fetus can deal with them just
fine yeah but when systolic and
diastolic go up that's just just high
pressure the whole time without any sort
of reprieve during during the the heart
cycle
um
so like like there's not just like
direct evidence that that's bad but it's
basically like we know the other thing's
good or the other thing is like safe
enough but like we don't know that that
is fine that like that blood pressure
signature is fine
um so they're they're they're pretty
leery about that
um also with with really heavy
resistance training
during especially the second and third
trimester you you have some hormonal
changes
um your body starts really releasing a
hormone called relaxin that I mean it
does what it sounds like it it relaxes
your connective tissues like your
tendons your ligaments
um largely to prepare the birth canal
for like actually giving birth nice
um because yeah like stuff that
generally is not moving it needs it
needs to move get out of the way so yeah
you have those hormonal changes which
which make yours your tendons and
ligaments a little bit laxer Yeah so
there's concern that that could increase
your risk for like serious uh sprains
and strains or or even just like an
acute like really bad injury like an ACL
tear or something like that
um
and for for supine exercise the concern
mostly has to do with the weight of the
fetus itself so two of your two of your
major blood vessels your inferior vena
cava which returns blood to your heart
and your aorta which is like your
biggest artery that takes blood away
from your heart
um they they basically run like behind
your internal organs pretty near your
spine and so if you have a lot of weight
of the fetus that's over them and then
you're laying on your back the weight of
the fetus might push down on those blood
vessels which could interfere with blood
flow interfere with blood returning to
the heart maybe make you lightheaded
maybe make you pass out
um so that that's where a lot of the
concern with supine exercise comes from
but you'd be lying down on your back in
other contexts right or do they tell you
like not to sleep on your back either
I'm not an obstetrician so I don't and
I've also never been pregnant so I don't
know what they recommend to you for
sleeping stuff I think they do generally
recommend sleeping on your side though
like I I'm yeah it seems like it'd be
uncomfortable to sleep on your back for
that reason I think just like supine
stuff in general is cautioned against
pregnant women but in particular supine
exercise because well then you're adding
additional oil well you might be
interfering with blood flow when you're
doing something that needs elevated
blood flow got it yeah
um so yeah that's that's where the
concern comes from for resistance
training above like 70 80 of 1rm
um valsalva maneuver and and supine
exercise
um but it is it is noteworthy that the
the caution towards those things and the
guidelines aren't based on Research
conclusively demonstrating that they're
dangerous it's more so that there are
there are mechanistic reasons to think
that maybe it could be dangerous
um
and there is insufficient evidence to
kind of like do away with those fears
yeah
um
and it's all like it's just generally in
keeping with the orientation of of the
maxim first Do no harm of course
um which uh fun fun little side note
about that first Do no harm a lot of
people say that that's kind of the the
first thing in the Hippocratic Oath it
wasn't uh it did not show up in the
Hippocratic Oath there there were
statements in there that kind of have
the same Vibe as that but the actual
like formulation of the statement first
Do no harm uh came from a speech from a
physician named Thomas edman in the
1800s just a fun little fact there damn
he gets no credit no sorry Thomas he
should he should
um
but yeah so
so basically this this is a slow process
um like expanding the types of exercise
that that are allowed or recommended to
pregnant women
um it took us like
70 years to get from you can do daily
walks but up up to a mile and in several
short intervals to uh okay most things
are probably fine and if you've been
doing vigorous exercise before you can
keep doing it like it took it took 70
years to get from point A to point B
yeah
um good for them for updating it though
so much you know I'm glad we got to this
point yes uh but but yeah so it is a
slow process definitely and
so let's let's kind of talk structurally
about why that is so lens if if you
wanted to change exercise guidelines for
pregnant women how how would you go
about it like how how would you set up
that that research program yeah I mean I
don't know because like it's obvious to
me that the reason why these things why
these guidelines are the way they are is
because you can't be putting pregnant
women in dangerous situations when you
might be endangering them in the fetus
so I don't know how you study
potentially dangerous things without
putting women in dangerous situations
okay so I do okay great if you find
women who already plan to put themselves
in dangerous situations yes yes
um so yeah when when uh doctors or
researchers think that a current
guideline like this might be a little
too conservative there's there's
generally a two-step process to address
it
um
like you said you you can't start with
randomized controlled trials yeah
because if if the medical consensus is
that this thing is dangerous
then if you set up an RCT uh and you
have you have one group doing what you
believe to be the dangerous thing and
another group it's just serving as a
control maybe doing either nothing or
something that's generally believed to
be safe there are uh two two outcomes to
that study
um either you're right and the
guidelines were too conservative and
like yeah this this thing is safe like
we can do it we can recommend it now or
uh General consensus is correct and now
you have uh badly injured pregnant women
or dead babies on your hands and uh no
dead babies irbs don't like dead babies
um there's so there there's a principle
in uh in research with human subjects
that
you
it's it's
so hard to get interventions approved
that there is a reasonable likelihood of
of harm coming to your research subjects
like there there are some contexts where
it's possible
um but it's it's so hard to get those
approved and generally the um
like the the like discriminating factor
is like if the if the benefits of it
outweigh the risks yeah to a large
enough degree like it can't it can't
really be debatable like yeah so so for
example like a drug trial with a drug
that
um they they think will save your life
but might also have some nasty side
effects like the the saving your life is
a is a bigger upside than the nasty side
of hexara downsides like you you can you
can get that approved but even that
might be difficult if the nasty side
effects are nasty enough yeah or if the
probability of it saving your life isn't
quite high enough like it's and in this
case we're talking about like hey
there's already so much other exercise
you could recommend that yeah that is
safe and effective that uh improves or
at least doesn't harm maternal Health
that improves or at least doesn't harm
fetal Health that the the marginal
benefit of doing heavy resistance
training versus the exercise that's
already recommended is so small that the
perceived elevation and risk that might
come along with it like you're you're
never going to get an Ethics to sign off
on it yeah so the it's so it's going to
be a two-step process the first step is
you find people who already are doing
the thing right that is thought to be
dangerous
and You observe them and if their
experiences suggest hey this probably
isn't that dangerous
then and generally it's not just going
to be one observational stuff you have
you have like a few observational
studies in the population of Interest
taking part in the activity of interest
and if if their cumulative data suggests
that like hey their their pregnancy
outcomes look really really similar to
the general population or better than
the general population then you can say
to an ethics board like hey the current
guideline suggests this is dangerous but
there's a there's actually a fair bit of
observational data now to suggest that
maybe it isn't dangerous so can we do a
controlled study to see if this is fine
and then if those go well then you
generally get updates and guidelines
okay and that's basically what's
happened up to this point so when they
were saying like hey don't don't walk
for more than a mile it's basically just
like hey let's let's find working women
who are on their feet uh while they're
pregnant just like working and moving
around more than that and guess what
their pregnancy outcomes are fine and
hey now we can do a little exercise size
study where we have some women not move
much and some women walk a couple miles
a day and like oh guess what they're
fine their babies are fine okay cool
like you can you can do some exercise
like that's that's the general process
that all of this stuff has taken yeah
and we're we've now reached the first
stage of that process for heavy
resistance training valsalva maneuver
and uh supine exercise cool so the study
I'm going to be talking about is called
impact of heavy resistance training on
pregnancy and postpartum Health outcomes
by previt and colleagues that that was
just published earlier this year
um
and so yeah this was an observational
study where they wanted to assess the
risk of continued heavy weight training
during pregnancy so
um
they they essentially wanted to recruit
women who were already doing heavy
resistance training who
either plan to or had continued doing
resistance training throughout pregnancy
and
um just see like hey do you have
negative Health outcomes from this are
there adverse fetal outcomes from this
does this seem to increase your risk of
pelvic floor dysfunction those things
like we're going to find people who are
already doing this stuff and look to see
if the scary outcomes people think will
happen if if those actually materialize
um
so yeah they they recruited uh lifters
to complete a questionnaire to take part
in the study subjects needed to have uh
to to have already engaged in resistance
training during pregnancy with loads
exceeding eighty percent of one RM
needed to be at least 18 years old
um and that I mean that was really about
it uh and they they got a pretty a
pretty solid sample for this so they
recruited a sample of 679 lifters in
total
um who
for the most part were either like
weight lifters so like Olympic style
weight lifters snatch clean and jerk or
or crossfitters and there were some who
did both some who did neither but it was
mostly like weight lifters and
crossfitters I think because they did a
lot of their recruiting via social media
and those were just kind of the people
in in their circles yeah
um
and
the like the survey itself was was
pretty big like it would have taken
about 20 or 30 minutes to complete and
it asked about a lot of stuff
um so like you know it asked about what
how did your training look like did you
keep training just as hard did you pull
back if you pulled back when
um it asked about just asking them to
recall previously this isn't yeah it's
not people who are currently pregnant
and like they're observing them yeah
okay uh yeah so it was it was like a
retrospective thing
um
and so it asked about uh like actual
complications during pregnancy so you
know did you experience preeclampsia did
you experience gestational diabetes
stuff like that
um asked about delivery complications
like did you need to get a C-section did
a labor and delivery take a super long
time or whatever
um asked about like fetal Health like
you know was was it a clean delivery
like is your baby doing fine
um and asked about postpartum stuff like
basically like how how long did did it
take you to bounce back right
um the end just all of the various
symptoms related to that and so I am not
going to go through all of the results
one by one because that would be boring
as [__] and there are there are there
are and I'm not exaggerating there are
literally hundreds of results
um but there was a digital appendix that
came with this article that that we can
link in the show notes and you can look
at every single individual outcome for
yourself but
um yeah just kind of in Broad Strokes
um
so most of the most of the women as you
would expect were in kind of like the
normal uh child bearing age like mid to
late 20s to early to mid 30s
um like I said most of them either did
CrossFit weightlifting or both
um
and uh about 85 percent
um continued engaging in heavy
resistance training during pregnancy 24
said they maintained their training
levels until delivery which I'm not
entirely sure what that means I don't
think maintaining training levels was
operationally defined but I I assume
that means ah like volume intensity
frequency like the just the general type
of level of effort yeah like that really
didn't change up until the point of
delivery which if so I mean that's
that's very impressive
um
72 percent continued uh weightlifting so
like snatching clean and jerk style
training uh during pregnancy 71 did
supine exercise and 34 use the valsalva
maneuver during pregnancy
um and and just in general uh rates of
pregnancy delivery and postpartum
complications were at or below rates
observed in the general population so
um
like rates of gestational hypertension
for instance were about three percent in
this study versus about seven percent in
the general population uh gestational
diabetes about one percent in the study
versus about eight percent in the
general population uh postpartum
depression and anxiety about seven
percent in this population versus about
17 in the general population
um the only outcome that and we'll talk
about this later but the only outcome
that on its face looked like a negative
in in this group of women was a higher
rate of postpartum urinary incontinence
than what's observed in the general
population so it was about 57 in this
study versus about 33 percent uh
generally
um although rates of incontinence didn't
seem to be predicted by the exercise
related variables in this study so like
the women who kept training hard during
pregnancy didn't have higher rates of
incontinence and the women who pulled
back a little bit the women who use the
valsalva maneuver during pregnancy
didn't seem to have rates of
incontinence higher than the women who
didn't so like yeah so that that was
kind of in aggregate finding but it
didn't seem to be predicted by the
actual like exercise variables they were
looking at right
um
so yeah like in in aggregate the results
were pretty were pretty promising
um
and uh
yeah so as for like the specific
concerns of the paper this is
um
is this a quote from my article or a
quote from the study I think it's my
article whatever uh but yeah so
um Olympic weightlifting training use of
the valsalvan maneuver and supine
training didn't seem to mean yeah this
is from my article this isn't from a
study uh Olympic weightlifting training
use of the valsalva maneuver and supine
training didn't seem to meaningfully
affect rates of pregnancy and delivery
complications however women who
maintained their pre-pregnancy levels of
training up to delivery had about 50
percent lower rates of pregnancy and
delivery complications than women who
scaled back their training with with
odds ratio they're being 0.49
um so yeah that's a that's a pretty
um a pretty noteworthy finding I would
say so
um lens what what would you take away
from these results uh does does this
show studies show that heavy resistance
training the valsalva maneuver and
supine exercise are are safe during
pregnancy by by your estimation
a review board if you wanted to do a
more controlled trial um
and I think like if I was a pregnant
person or if a pregnant person was
asking me for advice like I would find
this very heartening and obviously like
you know you want to feel what feels
right for your body but it does seem
like this is really
encouraging and
it's cool to see that
um some of these questions that remain
are starting to get answered yeah what
um
what what like lingering concerns would
you have after this study I would still
be nervous about doing belsalva I think
yeah that makes sense
um
and I don't really know if I have a good
reason for that other than just like the
description of of what valsalba is and
like what that does to your body
um
and it just
I don't think I don't think if I was
pregnant I would be
um lifting heavy enough that I would
want to do valsalva
um
that's fair yeah I got you
yeah so
so like like you mentioned this was a
study where like if you worked on an IRB
you'd look at this and say like ah okay
I I might green light and RCT right
um and yeah like I I think that's about
where I would be at as well but it is
important to consider that this is
observational research so it can't it
can't prove causation yeah of course so
um like in just something to point out
is in this study specifically there are
like multiple levels of selection biases
going on here okay so
the the population itself uh in this
study probably isn't super
representative of the general population
because like women who do heavy
resistance training are a self-selected
subset of all women right uh and then
women who continue performing heavy
resistance training during pregnancy are
a subset of women who do heavy
resistance training in general like some
some are going to be more concerned and
like I'm just going to train lighter
while I'm pregnant
um and then furthermore women who
completed this questionnaire and
participated in the study are a
self-selected subset of the women who
continue heavy resistance training
during pregnancy maybe they had a
particularly good outcome or like they
felt really strongly about the way that
they decided to be pregnant and they're
like I'm going to participate in this
study because I think I did it right a
little bit of uh
uh what would that be would that be
healthy responder by a social
desirability bias whatever I don't know
some some sort of bias I don't know what
any of those things
yeah that that's fine you don't need to
um but yeah so it at all three levels of
of self-selection here there are factors
that could influence rates of pregnancy
delivery or postpartum complications so
you know for example just just being
someone who does heavy resistance
training might be associated with other
health promoting behaviors like maybe
just generally higher levels of exercise
period yeah
um which you know those might be the
things influencing the positive outcomes
seen in the study rather than the heavy
resistance training itself
um
maintaining exercise habits during
pregnancy might be related to
maintaining other behaviors that would
promote a healthy pregnancy and delivery
so if you're the type of person who's
um you know going so yeah I mean so like
some some pregnant women kind of like
take pregnancy as an excuse to be like
and not I don't want to sound like I'm
blaming anyone for anything but it's
just like hey like I'm I'm gonna be the
queen for nine months I'm gonna wait
around gonna just like
I crave ice cream every night I'm gonna
eat a ton of ice cream just watch a ton
of reality TV and like honestly no judge
sounds fun like if if I could get away
with that for nine months maybe I would
who knows uh and like certainly so much
about pregnancy sounds [__] miserable
yes but it's like hey if if you don't
want to do it
and like that that's what helps it helps
you get through it like no judgment at
all for me
um but yeah like just in general like if
if you're maintaining heavy exercise
during pregnancy it seems like you're
probably less likely to go that route
right you're probably doing a lot of
other behaviors yeah a lot of other
health focused behaviors yeah you're
maintaining a lot of other you're
probably maintaining other lifestyle
factors that would probably predispose
you right to an easier delivery
um and and then like you mentioned just
by by choosing to opt into this study it
it very well could be that
you know if you did do heavy resistance
training during pregnancy and
um you know like let's let's say that
that did cause a miscarriage
not want to volunteer to participate in
this study right and admit that you did
something that yeah to that outcome you
know yeah
um
so yeah like you you for for all of
those reasons like you can't necessarily
draw causal inferences
um from this data and second if there
are causal relationships in play you we
can't necessarily use it to determine
the direction of the causation so uh for
instance like the the finding that um
the women who maintained their
pre-pregnancy levels of training had a
50 lower rate of pregnancy and delivery
complications in general that could be
because causally maintaining your
training level did cause those
beneficial outcomes or it could be that
if you were having pregnancy
complications that caused you to reduce
the level of training you were doing yes
so both both would result in the same
odds ratio right but you wouldn't be
able to tease out the direction of that
causation
um
so yeah that's that's just like one
General General consideration you know
um like another one is uh like the lower
rates of of postpartum depression
observed in the sample versus the
general population it could just be that
if you're someone who is
more prone to depression generally which
causes you know like lethargy low energy
like a lack of desire to exercise it
could just be that if you're someone who
is just generally predisposed to
depression
you're going to be someone who's like
less likely to exercise and vice versa
you know so yeah like it's hard it's
hard to know like if if these are causal
relationships what is the direction of
that causation
um so yeah there's there's still some
significant caveats but I I think the
general takeaway is is basically what
you said
um this is just like heartening
information that suggests that like
these things that are generally thought
to be dangerous
May again we don't know but may not be
quite as dangerous as people yeah
currently fear yeah so yeah we'll we'll
hopefully see another small handful of
observational studies and then that get
people comfortable enough to to actually
fund and allow a randomized control
trial to like actually like nail down
for sure like is is this stuff fine or
or is it not um
so yeah like don't don't expect this
study to result in like sweeping changes
to recommendations but it is kind of the
first step down that road
um
so let's just shift gears very quickly a
little bit to end on so I mentioned that
the the only like negative finding in
this study was that the the women in the
study generally had higher rates of
postpartum urinary incontinence than
women in the general population
um
what what do you know about urinary
incontinence and in women and like
lifters specifically
not that much I mean basically just kind
of like observing and like just knowing
lifters I think that it is a pretty
common thing for women and especially
for uh lifters like during deadlifts it
is not uncommon at all for a woman to
pee a little bit on the platform
um
and it seems like it definitely gets
worse for a lot of people after they
have had a baby yeah yeah for sure so
yeah I mean you you you basically nailed
it
um yes hell yeah found it so
yeah for for listeners at home and and
in particular male lifters because I or
male listeners because I assume the
women know this already like sometimes
women pee themselves a little bit when
they exercise and like that's like it's
it's not a terribly uncommon thing right
um I I think there's still generally a
fair bit of embarrassment that goes
along with it and I think a lot of that
embarrassment just comes from
how how people respond to it because
they think that it's abnormal you know
it's like hey this is this thing that
doesn't normally happen shouldn't happen
and like it's it's like weird and bad
that uh there's there's this woman who
like peed a little bit on the deadlift
platform or whatever and so like people
are kind of mean about it and that
increases the stigma and yeah people
people feel bad but that like it's it's
not it's not a super uncommon yeah I
don't know the numbers but just like off
the top of my head it feels like it
happens to like 40 of women like a lot
yeah so that's
um
that's actually like a pretty a pretty
good guess
um
yeah so uh yeah so in in this study it
was it was like 57 of the participants
right but in the general population it's
still like 33 and so like and that's
after childbirth yeah yeah okay
um so like in particular here we're
talking about stress incontinence so
there are a few different things that
can cause urinary incontinence and
stress incontinence is basically the
like there's some sort of like
mechanical perturbation generally an
increase in pressure that puts pressure
on the bladder yeah and that just like
causes some urine to leak out
um generally due to weakening or damage
to the pelvic floor muscles or I think
it's somewhat less commonly the the
urethral sphincter
um don't like that word it's not a great
word but that's the word I don't I'm
sorry I don't know what to tell you your
body has a lot of sphincters and I think
people feel weird about it because they
mostly only think of your butthole but
uh yeah okay you got you got sphincters
separating like everything had to tell
yeah like everything in your uh
digestive tract like there's one that
separates your esophagus from your
stomach there's one that separates your
stomach from your small intestine small
to large and then yeah you got you got
your butthole but okay sphincters are
useful and they're they're all over the
place okay anyways
um
but yeah so
I I think that I I wanted to address the
higher rates of of stress incontinence
seen in this study like relative to the
general population because I
I do think there is still the the
thought in some people's minds that like
lifting will increase your
your risk of developing stress
incontinence and I don't think that's
true
um I think that it is a
I think that it is observed more
frequently in lifters right because
because they're lifting yeah basically
so if if you have stress incontinence
basically if if uh enough pressure is
put on your bladder some urine will will
leak out and like it is what it is but
if you're not a lifter you're just going
through day-to-day life
um
when's that gonna happen like not yeah I
mean I frequently I think with some
women specifically postpartum it's like
sneezing sneezing or laughing coughing
yeah jumping yeah yeah a common one
um or or like picking something up like
if you yeah if you're not like doing a
Max deadlift but like yeah maybe you
need to move a dresser or something like
that you strain a little bit you pee a
little bit it is what it is yeah
um so like with stress incontinence it's
it's basically like a threshold problem
like if the pressure gets above kind of
your personal incontinence threshold
some some urine will leak out
and basically just like the the
intra-abdominal pressure and just like
the general pressure on your bladder
when you're pulling a Max deadlift or
doing a max squat yeah is just way way
more pressure right than you would be
putting on your bladder it's more than
like sneezing you know or laughing or
whatever definitely
um yeah I bet like a lot of the women
that it happens to while lifting it
doesn't happen when just like sneezing
or something yeah yeah exactly so I I
think that essentially what
what's going on here is that like
maybe like 50 of women would have a
little bit of incontinence if they
pulled a Max deadlift yeah and about 30
percent of women
would have a little bit of incontinence
not being a power lifter yeah and just
laughing sneezing coughing jumping
whatever and so it's essentially that
that 20 Delta
is just a matter of like hey it's it's
just because like 30 of women kind of
have a lower threshold 20 have a higher
threshold
if you're not a lifter if you would have
incontinence but it's kind of that
higher threshold thing you're just not
going to experience it because you're
not ever like putting that much pressure
on your bladder yeah whereas if if
you're a lifter you will yeah
um
so yeah that that's
you know like I'm I'm not a uh doctor
certainly and not like a specialist in
this area but that that's that's my read
of of this literature that
um if you have some sort of like if you
have stress incontinence it like lifting
will probably reveal that to you
but it probably doesn't actually
increase your probability of developing
incontinence or if you already have it
it probably doesn't actually make it
worse uh and in kind of the the evidence
supporting that is
um so like I said in this study it
the exercise variables themselves
weren't related to
um like the risk of postpartum
incontinence like the the women who kept
training hard didn't have higher rates
of postpartum incontinence than the
women who didn't like it it didn't and
like if exercise was the causal Factor
you would expect to see associations
between exercise variables and and rates
of the of uh postpartum incontinence
and there's also additional research on
power lifters so there was a 2021 study
by uh wakander and colleagues urinary
incontinence and competitive women power
lifters a cross-sectional survey
and I mean basically what they found is
that
[Music]
um
like
rates of incontinence were associated
with like age like rates go up as you
get older yep how many kids you have
yep and uh yep that's about it yeah yeah
um it was also it was also like
Associated to some extent
um with with years of power lifting but
years of power lifting is also
associated with 80 yes and that was a
time works yes uh and but that was a
like weak Association that was not
statistically significant same with
total years of strength training
um that was actually a weak negative
association also non-significant
um and so yeah like if uh
if it was like a causal thing that like
heavy resistance training actually
increased your risk
um you would expect there to be like an
exposure thing there like the longer
you've been doing it the higher the
rates are but yeah like it it just seems
like yeah if if you have more kids and
if you're older it's more likely to
happen yeah that's true for lifters it's
true for the general population and
lifting itself doesn't seem to
meaningfully affect your risk I don't
think are
um just like normal
lifting exercises that you would be
doing
able to
increase the strength of the pelvic
floor or is that something that has to
be targeted specifically oh man so I
I could wade into what I know to be a
pretty big uh argument oh no okay sorry
internet and I that was just like a off
the top of my head question yeah so I I
could but I'm not going to yeah please
don't uh but I'll I'll present the
perspectives that exist
um one is that
one one is that some like pelvic pelvic
Health Specialists think that
uh like lifting heavy especially with
the belts while doing the valsalva
maneuver
is actually bad for your pelvic floor
muscles and increases your rates of
incontinence so I whatever I'll wade
into it I don't think that's true but
the the the thing supporting it
basically is like if you conceptualize
your your abdomen as like a pressure
vessel which hey we know a lot more
about that due to the Titan sub disaster
yeah so um yeah yeah whatever this is
going to be a terrible analogy
um so just imagine
that you're you're uh the the the
circumference of your torso itself like
your tummy your sides your back yeah are
the walls of that pressure vessel and
yeah the your diaphragm is the is the
top of it or now let's go with the
bottom of it okay and then your pelvic
floor is like the the porthole that a
lot of people think oh no was the the
weakness the weak spot that made it go
um so if if you conceptualize it that
way
um essentially like as as you're
pressing down like your your diaphragm
is locked in it's not really going
anywhere you got a belt on around your
abdomen that's not really going anywhere
so if you have excess pressure that's
going to put strain on your pelvic floor
muscles and kind of stress them and
stretch them out a little bit
um
again like if that were true I would
think that like time spent competing and
powerlifting would be positively
associated with urinary incontinence and
it's not so I don't think that's what's
going on but that is a perspective that
yes okay that PL that plenty of people
who know who who have looked into this
way more than I have find credible so
that's just your Layman's opinion yeah
my Layman's opinion don't take it too
seriously don't get too mad at me so
that is one perspective
um the other perspective is that like Ah
that's like kind of neutral but
um
oh oh so so like to to continue that
perspective
um they they basically say that
um
so like the the belt like maybe that's
kind of sketchy who knows but you can
still lift heavy but it's it's better if
you don't use the valsalva maneuver
maybe don't use a belt but brace in a
way that as you're as you're tensing the
muscles with your abdominal wall you're
also like tensing and like pulling kind
of up and in on your pelvic floor
muscles yeah um and that like as as
you're doing that like that will
strengthen your pelvic floor muscles as
you're doing any other kind of exercise
so like it's it's something you can do
but it's maybe not something that would
be done by the way people would
generally brace for heavy lifting uh
the other the other perspective is
basically
mine which is just like
if it's probably fine
um
and like you you could you so basically
the the thing about like bracing
differently where you're like tensing
and like drawing up and in your pelvic
floor muscles like that that probably is
is good regardless
um but kind of the the alternate
perspective is like dude no you can
still wear a belt like you can do a
valve Salva maneuver as a power as most
power lifters would do it and that's not
going to like independently cause like
more weakness or damage to your pelvic
floor muscles but then like out
independent of like your heavy squats
and deadlifts you can just do like
pelvic floor muscle training yeah and
that's fine yeah
um
so yeah like those those are kind of the
two the two directions and either way
like you can do pelvic floor training
it's it's good for you like yes yeah
it's it's fine but yeah so that's that
that's what I got there okay
[Music]
um
so do you have any closing thoughts on
this topic Lindsay Lou
just um
heartened like we have we've used that
word a couple times now that these
exercise guidelines keep moving forward
um especially since it is kind of hard
to update them so you know
it seems like
a lot of research doesn't take women's
issues or like things that affect women
particularly seriously so it's nice to
see a body of literature that does seem
to be taking this seriously and does
seem to be like
putting in the work to make sure that
guidelines are being updated and that
women are able to like make choices and
um keep training if they want to and do
that in a way that they can feel good
about
and uh
I guess I just I salute the pregnant
women out here squatting in gyms and
having to deal with
everyone knowing all of the old exercise
guidelines and trying to tell them how
to live their life yeah yeah more more
power to him yeah not not a life I would
want to lead yeah yeah
um
all right so I I think that wraps up
this episode
um
thank you thank you for listening if
you'd like to give us any feedback uh
again the best places are probably the
stronger by science Facebook group or
subreddit
um
also as I mentioned previously we're
we're going to do audio q a so if you
have a question for the podcast record a
voice memo try to keep it under 30
seconds definitely keep it under 60. if
I open it and it's a minute and five
seconds I'm not listening to it like
don't send it if it's over 60 seconds
try to keep it under 30. uh send that to
you're laughing no I'm being serious I
know you're saying you're not listening
to a five minute question I know I don't
have the time or desire why I'm laughing
is because I think we just recorded like
a two hour episode and they're listening
to this and now we're being like we will
not listen to you for more than 60
seconds keep it brief I know because
that's the thing like we have too much
to say yeah you ask a question we're
gonna spend 45 minutes answering it if
your question itself is 10 minutes this
show is gonna get ludicrously long it
hasn't already but it will yeah so so so
keep it snappy like you you need to be
brief because we are incapable of doing
so
uh so yeah if you have those questions
send them to uh podcast at
strongerbyscience.com
um
if you enjoy the podcast rate review it
uh on whatever podcasting platform you
use make sure to subscribe to the show
if you haven't already and uh we're
excited to be back yeah we are